[music]
>> Is this mic on? Yes, this mic is on. How
we doing?
Woo! [\h__\h] fantastic. Yeah, let's go.
All right.
Um this I've This is So, the the title
of this is is about planning and review,
but I think the real point behind this
is like basically what are we all going
to do after AI continues to get really,
really good.
Uh
I'm Louie. I'm the founder of a startup
called Vibe Canvas, and I also started
the London chapter of AI Tinkers, uh
which is great community um if you're in
London looking for events.
And
you should listen to me because I have
done some stuff like get on the
SweeBench verified leaderboard ahead of
Open AI. This is a couple of months old
now, but anyway, you know, it's always
nice to know that the people talking
have done some research in the space.
Um
the agenda for today, class, is we're
going to uh I'm going to walk you
through why I have arrived at the
conclusion that basically all software
engineers are going to do all day is
plan and review stuff. And I'm going to
talk about how to think about balancing
that if that is what you do all day. Uh
I'm going to talk about time horizon and
how agents are getting uh running for
longer and how that changes the behavior
of the job. And then at the end, we're
going to shut my company down. And
[snorts] we'll get on to that later on.
So, let's get started. Everything is
plan and review. So, work that we
software engineers do. Who's Everybody
in here is a software engineer, right?
Yes. Okay, most people. Um we plan
stuff, we write code, we review code,
and we review other people's code.
Roughly, the work that we do.
The ratios until GitHub Copilot hit the
scene were roughly this for me. I know
it depends on whether you work in a big
company or a small company and things
like that, but a lot of it was writing
code and not very much of it compared to
that was planning and reviewing code.
And what we see is over time with things
like the first version of GitHub
Copilot, that basically the writing code
part starts to shrink. So, you know,
ChatGPT arrived, suddenly, you know, you
can like generate functions and paste
them in, and then Cursor, not Cursor
today, but like the original version of
Cursor arrives, and then it's like able
to complete a whole page of code. Um and
then you get Claude Code, and it's like,
"Wow, you know, I actually am not really
doing much code writing anymore."
Um so,
it kind of poses an interesting question
though, which is what, you know, say we
were spending 4 hours a day coding
before, does that mean I now get 4 hours
back if I'm not doing any actual coding?
The answer, of course, is no. It has
displaced work. Work that you or time
that was previously spent doing the
coding has moved. It has moved to
planning and reviewing. I think it is an
accelerant. You're probably getting more
done in the day, but it's probably like,
you know, you get uh 20 minutes back for
every half an hour that you were, you
know, spending coding, and some other
time has gone to planning and reviewing.
So, I want to talk about that. Like,
what is this new way of working? And I
think there's there's fundamentally two
approaches that people take. I'm not
going to get too specific about, you
know, I don't know, specs or uh
Playwright MCPs or things like that. I
think there's
tons of fascinating talks about that at
this event. I just want to kind of
conceptually ground what we're talking
about here today. So, the first way is
the plan-based approach. Um this is
where you spend a lot of time up front
planning the work that you want a coding
agent to do. So,
the smells of whether you are doing this
type of work would probably look like
you're writing a very comprehensive plan
doc, markdown file. You're maybe using
like one of these spec frameworks.
You're uh interrogating. So, you know,
I've seen some cool stuff where the
model asks you questions repeatedly
until it's like completely exhausted all
possible questions it could have about
what the work is that needs to be done.
The benefits of this, of course, are
that you basically spend less time
reviewing that work because you have
invested time up front
uh eliminating edge cases, giving the
the the models as much information as
possible about the work you're trying to
do. The outcome of that will be that it
the models less likely [\h__\h] up, and
you're going to get like better, better
outputs, and probably, you know, fewer
rounds of review. The downside is you
have to spend more time planning, but,
you know, that's just obvious, isn't it?
The other way of doing this, uh the the
other big way of working with AI is you
don't define a very detailed plan, but
instead, uh you let it, you know, run,
and then you you end up spending more
time reviewing that work. So, you know,
benefits of this, you can just YOLO
something, be like, "Ah, let's add a
contact form to the webpage." And then,
you know, the the the payback you have
to do is like you're going to go back
and forth a few times correcting the
styles, figuring things out. Um
I would say if you think about the
valuable thing being your human time,
and you have a choice, you always want
to be doing the first of these
behaviors, the planning the planning
approach, basically, because it will
save you a lot of time. It is very
time-consuming to have to switch back
and forth with an agent that is like
giving you some half-delivered work, and
you're constantly having to review it.
I think another way of breaking down the
modes of work, where one is plan and one
is review, is to think about the type of
thing that you're working on. And I
think feature development is actually
very different from migrations and uh
maintenance work. So, and front end is
very different from back ends. I was I
was trying to kind of think about this
before the talk, and this is the matrix
I've come up with, where basically, if
you're working on uh the front end and
you're doing feature development, it's
basically impossible to kind of really
spec everything out. There's so many
edge cases and you know, front end is
very stateful. Uh there's like
interactions, animations, styles,
there's functionality. And so,
personally, like I find it much better
to kind of be in the loop with a coding
agent. So, the second uh one of those
behaviors that we talked about. Uh but
for everything else, I think it really
is possible to be plan-heavy. So,
back-end feature development, you can
almost do test-driven development. And
for anything like refactoring and
migration-based, you certainly uh you
certainly can be doing that, and you
shouldn't be in the loop with any of
that work at all, really. That should
all be kind of test-driven
development.
So, the I guess if you had to distill
that long, meandering spiel into a
sentence, it would be spending 5 minutes
of planning saves you 30 minutes of
reviewing AI-generated code. And that's
basically the takeaway.
Uh the other thing that I think is kind
of interesting to consider is is how
things are running for longer. So, as
coding agents
become more capable, so as models get
better, as tool calling improves, you go
from calling a very small set of tools
to now, you know, the the coding CLIs
can call a a huge range of tools and do
testing and things like that.
The outcome of that is that every time
you send off a prompt, you are waiting
longer before it comes back to you and
says, "Hey, Louie, it's time for you to
do something."
So, to illustrate this, I mean, you you
know, like think back to GitHub Copilot.
It completes a single line of code, and
it takes seconds. Then you have like the
original Cursor completing a single
file, and that runs for, you know, 30
seconds. And then you have uh Claude
Code, which, you know, last year would
run for maybe a minute or two, and this
year I've I've been, you know, getting
some pretty good results with 5- or
10-minute executions. And that is going
to continue
because basically, we've gone from uh
you asking the AI to do something and it
just responds to the AI running a type
checker to the AI testing its change. I
mean, this is like the frontier of
things. And these things take increasing
amounts of time. Just returning the code
was really quick. Running the type
checker is a bit slower than that.
Running Playwright MCP is an order of
magnitude slower than any of those
things. Um but it's worth doing because,
you know, what you're trying to maximize
for, again, is how much time you are
spend or minimize, rather, is how much
time you are spending working with the
agent. So, you know, if you can get
higher accuracy by waiting longer, um
that is a a worthwhile trade-off.
And this is like where the frontier
probably is is like, you know, if I had
to forecast where we'd be at in 9
months' time, I would say basically, AI
starts to be able to QA front-end work,
and that's going to be a huge
breakthrough. You see some cool demos of
this on Twitter with, you know, Chrome
or Playwright MCP clicking around on
stuff. The reality is I haven't met a
single person who actually does this in
their in their mainstream development.
But I'm really excited for it, and I
think it will be the next major
breakthrough, where essentially, most of
the back and forth that you do with a
model is going to just be done by the
model itself because it'll be able to
actually run your project, click around,
and find the bugs, and make sure it's
done it. But this poses an interesting
question, which is like, what happens
when the average time that an agent is
running for exceeds, say 5 minutes. Cuz
I think 5 minutes is roughly the time
when you can like sit there and wait for
something, watch the logs, probably more
realistically like browse Twitter,
something like that.
And when we cross that 5-minute mark,
you have to change your behavior. You
know, imagine these things are going to
take 20 minutes to run. You're not going
to sit there for 20 minutes watching
agent logs. You're going to have to
think about coding and all the job of
being a software developer in a very
very different way.
Um this is something I'm sure
everybody's seen, which is, you know,
this kind of terminal maxing thing where
you you basically parallelism, right?
You run multiple of these things at
once. Say each of them take 10 minutes
to run. So, the way you get around the
waiting problem is you have multiple of
them on the go at any given time. So, as
soon as you finished, say reviewing one
piece of work, another has finished and
you can move on to that. And that's
basically what we started working on.
So, this is uh this is the the the
project we started about a year ago
called Vibe Kanban. And uh essentially
it started as as an attempt to make it
possible to paralyze agents very easily.
Um we built some cool stuff. There is uh
a sidebar where you can create multiple
workspaces that run any coding agent,
like Codex, Cool Code, things like that.
Uh
when you want to review the code, you
get the diffs. If you want to comment on
something, you can do it just kind of
like how GitHub does.
If you want to preview something or, you
know, click on something and kind of be
like, "Ah, actually make this a bit
bigger or that a bit smaller." You can
do that, too.
And you probably have seen all of this
stuff before, but you may not have seen
this stuff started as early as June
14th, 2025. We did it first, I swear.
Okay, so the considerations. I think
like what so so so human behavior is
going to change because agents are going
to cross this like 5-minute threshold.
Um and who knows, that may continue. You
may end up crossing an hour threshold.
So, we need new interfaces to make this
job
awesome. Cuz if you try and do it using
the existing tools, it kind of sucks.
You have to jump around reviewing code
in one thing, previewing things in
another. Um if I had a wish list for
what I would want the ultimate coding
agent tool for software developers to
look like, it basically embraced the
fact that I have to be a manager of
multiple streams of work at any given
time, which is not something most
software developers have had to do.
They've just been able to like lock in
in a in a deep way to one piece of work.
So, it's all about kind of I I put focus
maxing. I don't know if that's a word.
I'm coining it. You heard it here first.
Um but it should embrace the fact that
you can't pull humans out of something
and back into something else every 30
seconds cuz it just fries their brain
and it's not it's no way to live. Um so,
you know, it it should be built around,
you know, getting the most out of the
human so that an agent can run for as
long as possible and then yield back to
the human rather than encouraging
patterns where you're constantly jumping
in and out and in and out of needing to
get back into the context of what a
particular agent is doing.
It should help you write tasks and plan
things, obviously. It should help you QA
work because that's what a lot of the
human's work is going to be. And it
should help you do code review. I think
obviously code review, you know, a lot
of it's being done with AI, but very few
companies with money on the line are
actually going to
ship stuff that's fully Vibe coded
without actually checking the code. So,
reading code is probably something most
people in this room are going to still
have to do.
And then shepherding the change until
it's deployed, which is kind of a new
emerging one. So, you know, at its
simplest form, it's like monitor GitHub
pull requests and just look for comments
and kind of be reactionary to those
automatically. A lot of the admin
involved in getting something from I
finished the task to I've deployed the
task is just literally like, you know,
following comments and and reacting to
them.
So,
this
I wrote
I wrote this talk I I I submitted this
talk a few a few weeks ago.
And on Tuesday, I decided to shut the
company down. So, [snorts] I had a whole
basically there's a whole part of this
talk which was just me telling you more
about Vibe Kanban and trying to sell it
to you, but that's not going to happen
anymore because now the company's
shutting down. So, what I thought I'd do
instead is we can actually shut the
company down together. I haven't I
haven't actually announced it yet.
So,
>> [applause]
>> Okay, and we're going to do it using
Vibe Kanban, of course. It has to be,
you know. Okay, so uh please add a blog
post to the website
with this content.
Uh
>> [groaning and snorts]
>> and I've pre-written the uh
you know, the weepy the weepy note.
Okay, so we've got Vibe Kanban website.
All right, that's going to go and do it.
I can give you a little tour of this
thing as well. So, it's running a setup
script. What it's created a Git work
tree. It has run a setup script in the
work tree to install the dependencies
for our website.
And once that's done, it proceeds to uh
run whatever agent you've selected. I
use uh Codex most of the time, but it
supports eight of the most popular ones.
Um and it's going to go ahead and try
and figure out how to do that.
Um
what else is cool? Are you sad?
Am I sad? I think I've just done so much
thinking about it. I'm kind of relieved.
Like you run a you run a company for for
a few years and you have this like
enormous responsibility to kind of, you
know, you have staff and investors and
all this stuff and and I don't know, I
feel like a kind of weight has been
lifted almost. Um
we can talk through like why we're
shutting it down as well. We have we
have lots of you We have 30,000 monthly
active users and and 25,000 stars on
GitHub. And actually the project will
continue non-commercially. Um and we're
already pushing changes even though
we're we're shutting things down, but
it's actually very difficult uh to make
money in the current environment. Uh
the everybody who is making money is
doing two things.
They're selling to enterprise and
they're reselling tokens. And we were
doing neither of those things. We're not
a coding agent. We have a button that
helps you run something in Codex or or
Cool Code. And so, people can we we have
a subscription. People would spend like
$30 with us and then press a button that
helps them spend $3,000 with Codex. It's
just like not sustainable. Um and all of
our users are like individuals,
startups, uh smaller companies. And we
could have done the work, I think, to
address that and kind of move up into
the enterprise, but
you know, I don't know. It's uh it's a
kind of it's it's a mature market at
this point and
it's no fun playing for eighth place.
So, we decided to shut things down.
Uh okay.
Blog post is ready.
Let's see if it works. So, we've got the
live preview feature, obviously.
Let's wait for it to
compile.
Okay.
That looks good. So, we can go ahead,
open a pull request.
Uh
uncommitted changes. Oh.
Don't know what that's about.
Uh
Are we finding this out before your
investors?
Oh, [\h__\h]
>> [snorts]
>> Uh you're not. Don't worry.
Uh they most of Well, actually some of
them I need to I need to call them after
this. That's a really good point.
I'm fully committed to shutting this
down live on stage.
Okay.
All right, it's done. That's going to go
through Cloudflare's CDN.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you.
Um
I think we've got time for one or two
questions. I don't know if anybody in
the audience has a a one 1 minute 45.
Just
>> Steve?
What's next? Uh
take some time off, start another
company. My co-founders going to join
the lab. And most of the team have
already found good jobs at Agent Labs,
things like that.
Yeah.
Any other questions? [snorts]
Overall feeling
when you look back is positive or
negative Oh, yeah. No, I wouldn't I
wouldn't do anything differently. I
think like uh
it
it it it was like the most interesting
thing I've worked on and uh is right at
the cutting edge of like agents and all
of this stuff. I think certainly
I don't know. It's increased my value as
a human by doing this, so I would do it
all again. Yeah.
Go for it. What are the most valuable
things you've learned from
a few years of running a company?
Uh
most valuable things
I mean, just work with great people. You
know, we went through several rounds of
the team uh and the team we ended up
with was like phenomenally better. No no
offense to previous team, but that's
probably how to, you know, I think and
and hard work as well. I think like it
took us a while to learn like what hard
work really was. Um and you get to a
point that's like you're sitting there
at midnight with the, you know, the team
in the office on a Saturday and
everybody's kind of motivated and that's
yeah, it takes you a while to kind of
figure out how to get to that point. And
once you feel it, you know, kind of what
that's like. It's difficult until you
get there, I think.
Yeah.
Uh 12 seconds.
No? Okay.
>> Looking back to the past, what would you
change? What would I change? And I'd I'd
hire somebody who's really good at
selling to Enterprise.
All right, thank you very much.
>> [applause]
>> Cheers.
>> [music]